welcome to the macmillan report i'm
marilyn wilks your host and our guest is
erin dear a faculty member at osgood
hall law school professor dear is
currently at yale as the canadian
bicentennial visiting professor of law
at yale law school and a global justice
senior fellow at the macmillan center
his research interests include corporate
law governance and theory and the
intersections of transnational business
activity with international human rights
norms today we talk with professor dear
about his forthcoming book under
contract with cambridge university press
titled challenging boardroom homogeneity
corporate law governance and diversity
welcome professor dear thanks for having
me
so let's talk about the book give us an
overview
yeah so the book is essentially about a
core location of power in the global
marketplace and that's the corporate
boardroom okay and it looks at the
boardroom through the lens of
sociodemographic composition
so what are the groups that have been
permitted access to the highest levels
of the corporate hierarchy and what
groups have been excluded so for example
are you on social media yes okay so if
we think back to facebook's ipo that was
in 2012 and then twitter's ipo
just last november
with both of those ipos the firms
received scathing criticism because they
went public with all white all-male
corporate boards
and so just staying with gender for a
second if we look at the global
statistics they definitely indicate that
women are underrepresented in corporate
board rooms in senior management
positions etc
so in thinking about this issue i'm
primarily concerned in the book with
legal regulation
there's been a really interesting trend
over the last few years where
states
seeing the homogeneity in their
corporate boards have turned to law
as a means of attempting at least to
diversify the corporate boardroom and so
we see this in generally one of two ways
the first way is the quota based
approach so a number of states have
enacted corporate quotas for the board
room
and in their strongest form they
essentially obligate companies to have a
certain level of gender balance on the
board and then the second primary way is
through disclosure so that's a much
softer approach the idea is not that
we'll mandate a certain outcome but that
will get companies to publicly report on
diversity related governance information
the theory being that if you get them to
sort of bring this to the front of mind
and then publicly report that something
about that will cause behavioral
modification
interesting now are we talking the
united states only or globally so i'm
looking at this globally
and i've
taken on essentially two case studies so
my case study for the quota based
approach is norway and my case study for
the disclosure-based approach is the u.s
interesting i would have thought the
scandinavian countries or i've always
assumed anyway are much
better at having more of a gender
balance is that true or no yeah it is
true and i think what sort of struck
people in a place like norway was that
women were represented in many other
policy spheres but that the corporation
was the outlier and surprised by that
the government wanted to move forward
with humiliative measures very good
as a woman i say yay
what led you to write the book
what was the impetus right well
most of my work over the last few years
has actually focused on
corporate accountability issues so
uh transnational corporations operating
in the global south that are allegedly
complicit in human rights violations and
in working in that particular policy
space i've just consistently been struck
by the fact that
corporate board members senior
executives tend to be of a certain
demographic
and that just led me to think about
would the corporation's relationship
with
the environment or labor or human rights
be any different if primary decision
makers
weren't so
uniform a group if the group was a bit
more diverse right right
and
so in terms of your methodology how are
you um how are you doing this i mean
have you identified certain companies
within the united states and certain
companies within europe talk about that
a bit right so it's a mixed methods
approach so getting back to the quota
approach for norway
norway was the first country as i've
mentioned to pursue the quota and so
let's say you're a norwegian company and
you have a board that has nine members
under norwegian corporate law 40 of each
gender must be represented in the
boardroom
and if not
actually any guesses as to what happens
if not
it gets to be a woman
so in some countries if not the next
appointment must be a woman okay yeah
some countries have that approach in
norway if you don't meet the desired
level of representation the state will
just step in and forcibly dissolve your
company
wow it's incredible how awesome is that
quite the incentive huh it is quite the
incentive and so when the law passed um
there was very quickly a hundred percent
compliance for that reason so sorry go
ahead i'm i'm just shocked also by
rules in this country and then rules in
norway that the laws actually get passed
because i would imagine that thousands
and millions of dollars would just be
thrown at not allowing that to happen
yeah so time and time again i heard if
you want to get this done you need
extreme measures that's the only way it
will happen
so with norway i so i traveled to oslo
and i did qualitative interview based
research i interviewed a number of
norwegian directors about their
experience with the quota law and the
idea there is to understand
how does
mandated diversity inhabit their
everyday economic and institutional
lives
so then and then on the disclosure
approach
what i've done is
in 2010 the securities and exchange
commission which is the regulatory body
overseeing uh the issuance of shares and
and the public markets
it passed a law saying that
companies have to report on whether
diversity informs their director
nomination process and if so how
so i've assembled i've taken a sample of
the s p 100 and i've assembled their
corporate reports for the first four
years of the law and i'm analyzing the
discourse
how is this idea of diversity
discursively performed in their
corporate reports and so what what are
you finding
yeah so the findings are interesting
on the quota front
much of the policy discussion
internationally on quotas is very
negative the feeling being that
quotas will serve to
stigmatize the intended beneficiary
that people who come into the boardroom
as a result of a quota won't be sort of
well integrated that they'll be
marginalized and i was talking about
that so yeah and so i asked all of my
interviewees that question and i was
very surprised it was barely an issue
really yeah so they were embraced by the
rest of the board despite being a woman
i was very surprised
and i asked them what do they think
accounts for this and it's interesting i
think
for most of these directors their view
was they're absolutely qualified to be
in the boardroom it's just that there
were systemic barriers preventing their
access so of course they should be there
and it also seems to be
that the design of the norwegian law
facilitates a critical mass of
representation
so you can marginalize one or two
directors but if it's 40 of the board
how can you realistically do that right
right and then my finding on the
disclosure front is interesting too
because when the sec designed this law
this rule
it decided not to define diversity
it thought you know what let's let
corporations report on diversity however
it makes sense to them within the
context of their specific business
operations
so i'm sorry diversity then could mean
uh a hispanic man versus a woman is that
what could okay but what's interesting
is that
firms only talk about diversity in
socio-demographic terms so gender erase
about half of the time
half of the time and most
predominantly they talk about diversity
vis-a-vis experiential factors the
backgrounds of their directors etc
uh-huh
so that's not really helping the cause
though i would imagine in terms of
getting more women that's the right
so is that is that
what's happening
yeah
that because of the vagueness really of
the law that that's there it's a
loophole basically
it's interesting because the sec
has said that their official position is
that they were not trying to
mandate conduct or steer behavior
but when you look at the responses of
market to participants when it first
proposed the rule they clearly wanted
information on factors like gender and
race so
the sort of
common understanding is that this was
about diversification in those areas
even if that's not the official position
but that's not what's happened which is
really interesting so do you think
anything will happen now because of that
so that will be uh part of my
recommendations in the book will be that
although disclosure is a favored
regulatory tool in the us
in this case
you know the devil's in the details so
in this case it was a gentle nudge
but what's really needed is a bit of a
harder shove right right
so
in terms of the corporations and i
imagine there are some in in the united
states that are hiring women based on
that law or
versus when you look at what happened in
norway
are the women who are hired here did you
look at how the women did you interview
any women hired here in terms of how
they are being received right no so my
qualitative research the interview based
research uh was focused on norway so
it's a content analysis i'm doing for
the us and also because the law was only
passed in 2010 it's very early so it's
hard to know the effects but i think
going forward doing interviews with uh
female corporate directors in the us for
example will be a great follow-up study
so in in the course of doing your
research was there anything that struck
you as odd or surprising
yes something you didn't expect i i
think both of those things that i just
mentioned the fact that quotas are not
sort of seem to be
the effect of them is not seen to be
marginalization but rather of
democratized access
and the fact that diversity discourse
under the u.s rule tends to be more
about experiential factors and
background rather than about gender and
race right so moving forward um you know
what do you think the trend will be
both in norway and here
yeah united states it's interesting uh
norway the law was very very
controversial but i have the sense that
things have settled down now
and it'll be since that time it's really
interesting because
uh subsequently
countries like uh italy iceland belgium
france have all followed suit and passed
quota based measures so whether that
spreads even further it'll be
interesting to watch and to watch for
and see and then in the u.s
i'm going to recommend in this book that
the sec take
another look at this rule
and design it with a bit more of a
forceful shove
and the underlying argument will be
that because the norms of diversity
haven't infiltrated the boardroom yet
that just getting companies to talk
about it it might be a helpful first
step but it's limited in its utility
what do you think is the the main
reason for not being more accepting of
women at that level
i don't think it's an issue of
most of the time i don't think it's an
issue of explicit discrimination i think
a lot of the time it's implicit
cognitive bias
certain assumptions that we hold about
who should uh take on leadership
positions and it's also about closed
social networks at the end of the day
people are tapped for corporate
boardroom positions through their
networks through the existing networks
of directors who do they know and so
time after time the norwegian directors
told me that one of the real benefits of
the law is that it forces boards to go
outside of traditional networks to other
spaces right right and i think that i
think that really
helps a company grow bringing you know
new ideas and new people in so i think
it would behoove us in this country to
do the same thing also um one uh one
last question geographically in the
united states do you notice a big
difference in corporate makeup for
instance perhaps more women in the
northeast versus the south that kind of
thing i haven't actually studied that
aspect but i think i think you're right
as a follow-up study that would be
really interesting too i have thought
about it a little bit just in terms of
industry so in certain industries you
see better representation than others
the extractive sector for example mining
metals oil and gas tends to be pretty
bad um and the argument they'll make is
that they don't have women coming up
through the pipeline in those industries
right yeah that makes sense so when will
your book be out uh so
it's uh it's uh under contract with
cambridge university press and the
manuscript should be off to them within
a matter of weeks and then it'll go
through the production production cycle
and very soon okay well congratulations
on that and thank you very much for
being here with us today thanks so much
for having me sure
for more information about professor
dear and his research please visit our
website at yale.edu mcmillan report be
sure to join us again for another
episode of the macmillan report made
possible through funding from the
whitney and betty mcmillan center for
international and area studies at yale
you